the entire  world is a collection of memoranda that  she did exist  and that i have lost her this is our  story  tessa's and mine  we're like an addiction to each other  with equal parts pleasure  and pain you hurt me and i can't forgive  you  tessa i want another chance  [Music]  i'll try whatever it takes harden's your  son  but he is not without his challenges  [Music]  is he sorry  can you hold the elevator please  tessa welcome to vance publishing she  makes quite the impression  wow  let me ask you this are you in love with  him  you're never gonna trust me trust you  where has that  ever gotten me i thought that things  were getting better  but i don't know how to fix it  there is no you're tessa anymore  [Music]  together  whatever our souls are made of his and  mine are the same  there's no one else for me tessa noah  [Music]  you